question and could you see that you know
reverting back to the patronage of the
Medici could you see a downside of that
yeah I don't know that that feels a
little quirky to me um because I think
it implies decentralized funding I don't
think you need decentralized funding
like you know all these systems of
decentralized networks they're not
necessarily the best way to solve a
problem like
um you know if you remember back in the
day Skype was like a peer-to-peer like
communication system and the latency was
high and the a lot of bits were lost
along the way and so Skype didn't end up
winning right like zoom and and Google
meet and Microsoft teams won because
they had a more robust centralized
Network model that worked uh the data
would be transmitted to the center of
the network and more efficiently routed
back to the uh to the consumer and uh
same with a company called youth which
made this peer-to-peer video sharing
mapster all these peer-to-peer systems
were less efficient
um they're kind of trying to solve a
problem uh in the least efficient way or
in a less efficient way than maybe a
centralized model